diversos pronunciamientos tras conocerse
los resultados en los que sergio garrido
candidato opositor obtuvo 14 puntos
porcentuales por encima del candidato
del oficialismo jorge arriaza la
participación aún mayor que el pasado 21
de noviembre se estimó en
51% organizar se pronunció más temprano
para asegurar que fue una derrota
cuantitativa pero lo calificó como una
victoria cualitativa pues aseguró que
durante la campaña vio resurgir el
chavismo en barinas también lanzó
advertencias a la oposición los llamó
administrar su victoria y asegurar que
el oficialismo sería que seguiría muy
pendiente y al lado del pueblo en
barinas también se pronunció en juan
guaidó felicitando los resultados de
esta elección y también destacando que
pese a que fue una campaña con mucha
desventaja para la oposición y se
utilizaron todos los recursos del estado
el resultado fue contundente llamó
también a la oposición a que utilicen
estos resultados como una coyuntura para
entender que unidos pueden lograr la
movilización y organizarse de cara a
unas eventuales elecciones
presidenciales o un eventual
el revocatorio el primer acto que
realizó el gobernador electo sergio
garrido fue acudir a una misa en la
catedral de barinas para agradecer lo
que fue esta jornada una victoria con
gran simbolismo para la oposición pues
recordemos era un estado que estuvo
gobernado durante 22 años por la familia
del fallecido presidente hugo chávez